does the Disney plus series Ahsoka get
to hyperspace or is it stuck in the
swamps of Dagobah luckily most critics
are saying the former is the case
reviews for the first two episodes of
Ahsoka are out and critics are making
their verdicts known about the latest
Star Wars series
both a continuation of story lines from
the Mandalorian and a direct sequel to
The Animated Series Star Wars Rebels
it's a sprawling Jedi Adventure in the
classic Star Wars style complete with
all of the white Transitions and musical
cues you'd expect it's also receiving
widespread praise in early reviews
Disney has had a bit of a rough time
with the streaming era of Star Wars
though the first season of the
Mandalorian is arguably the most
universally beloved entry in the
franchise since lucasfilm became an arm
of Disney subsequent TV series have
failed to capture that same excitement
the book of Boba Fett was met with a
lukewarm reception and while Obi-Wan
Kenobi has plenty of fans it also
received a lot of criticism for poor
production values and bizarre pacing
issues Andor has been the one truly
Shining Light for the franchise on
Disney Plus in recent years with even
the third season of the Mandalorian
coming and going with much less Fanfare
than its predecessors but now it seems
that Disney May once again have a Star
Wars hit on the streamer as of the
making of this video Ahsoka has a
critical approval rating in the low 80s
on reveal aggregator Rotten Tomatoes and
don't miss this time the early reviews
for Ahsoka which cover the first two
episodes made available to the Press
point out a number of flaws but they're
generally quite kind to Creator Dave
filoni's new live-action show Ed power
of the Daily Telegraph wrote in his four
star review Ahsoka has two qualities
lacking from much recent Star Wars
output a solid story and an imaginative
visual Twist on George Lucas's Universe
Dan Jolin of Empire magazine echoed the
praise writing fans of Clone Wars and
Rebels will appreciate this live-action
continuation of Dave filoni Saga while
newcomers should dig its promise of a
different kind of force Clash other
critics were a bit more reserved in
their compliments Bob Strauss of the San
Francisco Chronicle wrote Ahsoka has a
fresh feel it would be fresher though if
Star Wars could just find new themes to
explore and do so in ways that don't
require so much standing around talking
Nick Shaker of The Daily Beast praised
the show but critiqued the barrier to
entry writing no matter how hard it
strives for widespread accessibility
it's a sequel that will be of primary
interest to established fans though the
early reviews are quite strong Ahsoka
still has a lot to prove the first two
episodes are the only ones that have
been made available to critics before
release there are still six more
episodes to come those will determine
what kind of lasting Legacy Ahsoka
actually has in the grand scheme of the
Star Wars franchise Nick Hilton of the
independent penned one of the less
favorable reviews of the show writing
the production design is as flat and
flimsy as the characterization Ahsoka
herself is on paper a badass but on the
screen she feels joyless things have
changed stilted dialogue and the
lingering production hindrances of the
volume which is what Disney calls its
massive LED soundstage are the main
criticisms early viewers have lodged
against the series Ahsoka has plenty of
Runway to work past these issues but
whether or not it succeeds in that
mission remains to be seen Ben traver's
review of the first two episodes for
indiewire reminds fans that whatever the
lasting image of the new show at least
we still have Andor
foreign